Seriously, America? Is this one so hard? This seems like an easy layup-- a 4-inch putt, a slow pitch across the plate, a thing that's so easy that even somebody like me who doesn't care about sports finds himself making sports metaphors. I'm talking about the DREAMers, the DACA kids who were brought to the US as small children. The majority of Americans have wanted to give them a path to citizenship since 2010.
说真的，美国？这很难吗？这看起来像是个简单的上篮——一个4英寸的推杆，一个投向本垒板的慢球，事情简单到连我这种不关心体育的人都会随口用上体育比喻。我说的是“梦想家”，那些小时候被带到美国的DACA儿童。自2010年以来，大多数美国人都希望给予他们入籍的途径。
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham quoted a Fox News poll on the floor of the Senate this week that shows 79% of the public supports that, including 63% of Trump voters. Leaders of both parties in the House and Senate say they want it. The president says he wants it. In other words, it's super popular. Politicians support it. And yet, we've been trying 2001-- 2001! And we still don't have a permanent fix to this.
共和党参议员林赛·格雷厄姆本周在参议院引用福克斯新闻的一项民意调查显示，79%的公众支持这一点，其中包括63%的特朗普选民。两党在众议院和参议院的领导人都表示他们想要这样做。总统也说他想要这样做。换句话说，这非常受欢迎。政客们支持它。然而，我们从2001年就开始尝试了——2001年！我们至今仍未得到一个永久的解决方案。
There's this thing that President Trump said about his job on his 98th day in office. He said, "I thought it would be easier," which, OK, he was roundly mocked for that. But weeks like this one, I think that too. Like really, with so many things, I really thought our democracy could do these things. Like, why is it not easier?
特朗普总统在他上任第98天时说了关于他工作的一件事。他说：“我以为这会更容易。”好吧，他因此受到了广泛的嘲笑。但在像这样的一周里，我也这么想。真的，面对这么多事情，我确实以为我们的民主体制能处理好这些。为什么就不能简单点呢？
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, in this week of government dysfunction, we have two stories of lawmakers not able to accomplish tasks that seem, from the outside, very straightforward. Act One of our show is about Republicans. Act Two is about Democrats. Specifically with the Democrats, what are they doing? A year into the Trump presidency, what exactly is their plan? Why does it seem to be, you know, nothing? Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目里，在这个政府功能失调的一周，我们要讲述两个关于立法者无法完成在外界看来非常直截了当的任务的故事。第一幕是关于共和党的。第二幕是关于民主党的。具体到民主党，他们到底在做什么？特朗普执政一年了，他们的计划到底是什么？为什么看起来好像什么都没有？请继续收听。
Act One, Send in the Gowns.
第一幕：带上袍子。
President Trump hasn't got a chance yet to build his wall. One of the first things he did in office was to issue an executive order of what to do when people are caught crossing the US border. Even under President Obama, most of those people got kicked out right away through a process called expedited removal. But there were lots of people who got locked up, processed, and released after a few weeks into the United States while they waited for their day in court, which could take years. And then, often, they didn't even show up in court. It was kind of a mess. Border agents called it catch and release. You probably heard that phrase.
特朗普总统还没有机会建造他的隔离墙。他上任后做的第一件事就是发布了一项行政命令，规定在抓捕越境人员时该怎么做。即使在奥巴马总统任内，这些人中的大多数也会通过一种叫做“快速驱逐”的程序被立即赶走。但有很多人被关押、处理，并在几周后被释放到美国境内，等待出庭，这可能需要几年时间。而且，他们往往根本不出庭。这简直是一团糟。边境特工称之为“抓了就放”。你可能听过这个词。
The Trump administration wanted to get rid of catch and release. And so rather than do that, they decided they were going to take this group of people, detain them, and then get them in front of a judge fast, and then quickly deport anybody who should not be here. That, of course, required judges, more than they had at the border at the time. So they started flying immigration judges from around the country from their regular courtrooms to courts near the border. They would be there for two weeks at a time. And so this is an example of politicians seeing something they wanted to fix. They came up with a straightforward plan to do it. And we wanted to know, how's that working?
特朗普政府想要废除“抓了就放”。因此，他们决定与其那样，不如把这群人关押起来，让他们尽快面对法官，然后迅速驱逐任何不该留在这里的人。当然，这需要法官，比当时边境现有的法官还要多。于是他们开始从全国各地将移民法官从他们的常规法庭调往边境附近的法庭。他们每次要在那里待两周。这是一个政客们看到想要解决的问题的例子。他们提出了一个直截了当的计划。我们想知道，这管用吗？
Well, to answer that, we collaborated with The Marshall Project and their reporter, Julia Preston, who's visited immigration courts for over a decade in her old job as the immigration correspondent for The New York Times. She's broken many stories of this subject. She went with one of our producers, Jonathan Menjivar, to one of these courts. This one was inside a detention center in Laredo, Texas. Here are Jonathan and Julia.
为了回答这个问题，我们与“马歇尔计划”及其记者朱莉娅·普雷斯顿合作。她作为《纽约时报》的移民通讯员，在旧职期间曾走访移民法庭十多年。她报道过许多关于这一主题的新闻。她和我们的制片人乔纳森·门吉瓦尔一起去了其中一个法庭。这个法庭位于得克萨斯州拉雷多的一个拘留中心内。下面是乔纳森和朱莉娅的报道。
The first thing that happened when we got to this immigration court in Laredo was that we couldn't even get inside. Immigration courts are supposed to be open to the public, but this court, it's inside the detention center, which is run by a private prison company. So to get in, you have to get past an employee who's sitting behind a thick glass window.
当我们到达拉雷多的移民法庭时，发生的第一件事就是我们甚至进不去。移民法庭理应向公众开放，但这个法庭位于拘留中心内，而拘留中心是由一家私人监狱公司运营的。所以要进去，你必须通过一名坐在厚玻璃窗后的员工。
It was October when we visited, and the window was covered in Charlie Brown Halloween stickers-- Lucy in a wizard costume, Snoopy napping on a jack-o'-lantern. We'd made arrangements in advance with ICE, the Federal immigration enforcement agency, to let them know we were coming. But it didn't help.
我们去的时候是十月，窗户上贴满了查理·布朗的万圣节贴纸——穿着巫师服装的露西，在南瓜灯上打盹的史努比。我们提前与联邦移民执法机构ICE安排好了，告知他们我们要来。但这没用。
Eventually, we are cleared to enter. You're not allowed to record in court, so you're not going to hear any audio, but I'll just tell you. When we get into the courtroom, I realize I've met the judge before. His name is Barry Pettinato, and I met him when I was reporting a story last summer back in his home courtroom in Charlotte, North Carolina.
最终，我们获准进入。法庭内不允许录音，所以你听不到任何音频，但我可以告诉你。当我们走进法庭时，我意识到我之前见过这位法官。他的名字叫巴里·佩蒂纳托，我去年夏天在他北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的家乡法庭采访时见过他。
In Charlotte, Judge Pettinato was fully in command, and he was running a fast-paced, no-nonsense courtroom. He has a record as a tough judge. It's not easy to win an asylum claim with Judge Pettinato. In Laredo, he told us he was in the second week of a two-week stint. He kind of jokingly asked me if I was following him around.
在夏洛特，佩蒂纳托法官完全掌控局面，他经营着一个节奏快、讲效率的法庭。他作为一名严厉法官是有记录的。在佩蒂纳托法官手下赢得庇护申请并不容易。在拉雷多，他告诉我们他正处于两周任期的第二周。他半开玩笑地问我是否在跟踪他。
Pettinato's courtroom in Laredo was hastily arranged last March to accommodate a judge. It's a cramped space with no windows, with the judge and the immigrants up very close to each other. But there is one of those raised wooden podiums for the judge, so it looks enough like a court.
佩蒂纳托在拉雷多的法庭是去年三月匆忙安排的，以容纳一位法官。这是一个没有窗户的狭窄空间，法官和移民离得很近。但那里有一个法官用的那种升高的木制讲台，所以它看起来确实像个法庭。
Judge Pettinato takes the bench and, right away, it's clear that things aren't going as smoothly as they did in his home court in Charlotte. Pettinato has this big stack of blue files, and initially, it's not clear which case he's supposed to hear. An immigrant is called who has the identity number 991, but the government doesn't seem to have the file for that person. In fact, it seems that person may already have been deported. But they do have a file for immigrant 919. Maybe they're supposed to hear that case instead?
佩蒂纳托法官坐上法官席，很明显，事情不像他在夏洛特的家乡法庭那样顺利。佩蒂纳托有一大堆蓝色文件，起初，并不清楚他该审理哪个案件。叫到了一位身份证号为991的移民，但政府似乎没有那个人的档案。事实上，那个人可能已经被驱逐出境了。但他们确实有移民919的档案。也许他们应该审理那个案子？
"Was that just bad data input?" Judge Pettinato asks. It isn't even 9 o'clock in the morning and he already seems exasperated.
“那是数据录入错误吗？”佩蒂纳托法官问道。还没到早上9点，他就已经显得十分恼火了。
We soon find out he's not the only one. During a break between cases, the government attorney-- he's the immigration court equivalent of the prosecutor, and someone who generally wouldn't talk to the press-- he walks up to us and seems eager to share his frustration. He tells us the whole Laredo court is, quote, "just a bad setup." He explains how it works, or rather, how it doesn't really work.
我们很快发现他不是唯一一个这样的人。在案件间隙休息时，政府律师——他相当于移民法庭的检察官，通常不会与媒体交谈——他走过来，似乎急于表达他的沮丧。他告诉我们，整个拉雷多法庭简直是“一个糟糕的设置”。他解释了它是如何运作的，或者更确切地说，它是如何无法运作的。
The judges come and go every two weeks. The clerks also come and go every two weeks. But the clerks don't necessarily come with the judges, so the judges may be working with clerks from some other part of the country they've never met before. There are two attorneys for the government. They come and go every four weeks. The Spanish language interpreters, who have to be in the court much of the time, are also coming and going. Everyone is coming and going. And there's no overlap between one rotation of judges or prosecutors and the next rotation. The government attorney tells us the result is just plain chaotic.
法官每两周换一次。书记员也每两周换一次。但书记员并不一定随法官而来，所以法官可能是在与全国其他地方他们从未谋面的书记员一起工作。政府有两名律师。他们每四周换一次。必须大部分时间都在法庭上的西班牙语翻译也换来换去。每个人都在换。每一轮法官或检察官与下一轮之间根本没有交接。政府律师告诉我们，结果就是一片混乱。
A few minutes later, Judge Pettinato spends some time trying to get one lawyer on the phone, but it keeps disconnecting. Next up, there's an Albanian who agrees to participate in his hearing in Spanish, even though he doesn't really speak Spanish. "Me hablo mucho Italiano. Entiendo un poquito Español," he tells the interpreter. I speak a lot of Italian. I understand a little Spanish.
几分钟后，佩蒂纳托法官花了一些时间试图给一位律师打电话，但电话一直断线。接下来是一位阿尔巴尼亚人，他同意用意大利语参加听证会，尽管他并不真正说西班牙语。“我懂很多意大利语。我也懂一点西班牙语，”他告诉翻译。
The more time we sat in the courtroom, the more I realized we were noticing things I had never seen in years of observing immigration courts. There was no posted hearing schedule. Case files often went missing.
我们在法庭里坐的时间越长，我就越意识到我们注意到了一些我多年来观察移民法庭从未见过的东西。法庭没有张贴听证日程表。案卷经常丢失。
Judge Pettinato was trying to move things along, but instead of efficiency, there were time-consuming mishaps and delays. And as a result, immigrants who were detained and anxious and who expected to have an orderly process and a fair hearing weren't really getting that. Nor were they getting the speedy treatment the Trump administration intended, or anything close.
佩蒂纳托法官试图推进进程，但没有效率，只有耗时的事故和延误。结果，那些被拘留、焦虑不安，原本期待有序流程和公平听证的移民并没有得到这些。他们也没有得到特朗普政府所预期的那种快速处理，甚至完全不是那回事。
A lot of the fumbling happens because of a simple dumb reason. All of the files are still kept on paper. All immigration courts around the country work this way, but it's an especially big problem in Laredo.
很多失误是因为一个简单且愚蠢的原因。所有的文件仍然是纸质的。全国各地的所有移民法庭都是这样工作的，但在拉雷多这是一个特别大的问题。
During one hearing, there's a lawyer, this guy who's driven up three hours from Weslaco, Texas. He's there to ask for a bond so his client can be released. But here's the hiccup. The files for this court in Laredo, they're not actually in Laredo, at least initially. They're filed in another immigration court 150 miles away in San Antonio. And every case file, it has to be physically sent here. And sometimes they don't make it, like with this lawyer.
在一次听证会上，有一位律师，是从得克萨斯州韦斯拉科开车三个小时赶来的。他来这里是为了请求保释，以便他的委托人能被释放。但问题出在这里：这个拉雷多法庭的档案，起初根本不在拉雷多。它们归档在150英里外的另一个圣安东尼奥移民法庭。每一份案卷都必须被物理运送到这里。有时候它们没送到，就像这位律师的情况一样。
"You may have submitted it, but we don't have it," Judge Pettinato says to the lawyer. "I filed it in San Antonio," the lawyer says. "Well, that could explain it." Judge Pettinato's eyes roll as he says this. It's a strange thing to see in a courtroom, a judge openly mocking the flaws of the court he's running. Even stranger are the knowing nods in the room. Everyone here-- the lawyer, the clerk, the government prosecutor, even the interpreter-- they know this hearing can't go forward because of the haphazard way this courtroom has been set up.
“你可能提交了，但我们没有，”佩蒂纳托法官对律师说。“我在圣安东尼奥提交的，”律师说。“好吧，那就能解释通了。”佩蒂纳托法官说着翻了个白眼。在法庭上看到这一幕很奇怪，一位法官公开嘲笑他所主持的法庭的缺陷。更奇怪的是房间里那些心知肚明的点头。这里的每个人——律师、书记员、政府检察官，甚至是翻译——他们都知道这次听证会无法进行，因为这个法庭的设置方式太随意了。
Judge Pettinato sets the bond hearing for a week out-- a time, remember, when some other judge will have replaced him. The guard then escorts the woman from Honduras that this whole hearing was about out of the courtroom. She's stuck in detention for another week, having no idea what will happen with her case.
佩蒂纳托法官将保释听证会推迟到一周后——记住，到那个时候，会有另一位法官接替他。然后警卫把那位来自洪都拉斯的妇女带出了法庭。她被困在拘留中心又多了一周，根本不知道她的案件会怎样。
When you start asking around in Laredo for someone who really knows what's going on in this court, there's one lawyer whose name keeps popping up-- Paola Tostado. She's a real Texas highway rider lawyer from Brownsville, three hours to the south. She makes the drive to Laredo sometimes three times a week, keeping an eye out for a Texas breed of antelope called a nilgai. It's the size of a horse, and it can appear on the highway at 5:00 in the morning when she's driving to court.
当你在拉雷多四处打听谁真正了解这个法庭时，有一个律师的名字总是被提及——保拉·托斯塔多。她是来自南部三小时车程外的布朗斯维尔的真正的得州公路骑手律师。她有时每周开车三次去拉雷多，留意着一种叫尼尔盖羚的得州羚羊。它有马那么大，当她凌晨5点开车去法庭时，它可能会出现在高速公路上。
While most lawyers were wearing muted black in that dingy detention center, Paola announced her presence with a scarlet dress and 4-inch spike heels. And in a court filled with all these rotating judges, Paola, this young lawyer who graduated from law school in 2015, she seemed to have become a resident expert. We saw Judge Pettinato defer to her judgment a couple of times when she was in court. She's very persistent and confident.
当大多数律师在那阴沉的拘留中心穿着素雅的黑色服装时，保拉穿着红色的裙子和4英寸的细高跟鞋宣告着她的存在。在这个充满各种轮换法官的法庭里，保拉这位2015年才从法学院毕业的年轻律师，似乎成了驻地专家。我们看到佩蒂纳托法官在法庭上几次听取她的意见。她非常坚持且自信。
Paola told us she had this case that was emblematic of the messed up situations lawyers and immigrants find themselves in when a court isn't running properly. The case involved a guy from El Salvador who wanted to appeal after he didn't pass his first asylum interview. Paola drove up to San Antonio to speak with the court clerk and see her client's file.
保拉告诉我们，她有一个案子，象征着律师和移民在法庭运作不正常时所陷入的混乱局面。这个案子涉及一名萨尔瓦多男子，他在第一次庇护面谈没通过后想要上诉。保拉驱车前往圣安东尼奥与法庭书记员谈话，查看她客户的档案。
And the court clerk informed me that the case was closed, that the judge had closed the proceedings.
法庭书记员通知我，案件已经结案，法官已经结束了诉讼程序。
Meaning his case was over. Done.
意思是他的案子结束了。完了。
And I said, well, that's impossible because my client is still in detention. And she's like, well, if you can give me some sort of proof that he is still in detention, which is ridiculous.
我说，那不可能，因为我的客户还在拘留中。她说，好吧，如果你能给我一些他还在拘留中的证明，这简直可笑。
Ridiculous because the proof that he was in detention was that he was still in detention. But the clerk had no record of that. The problem was that, if the case was formally closed, to get any order from the court to have the man released, Paola would need to get the case reopened. She tried ICE, the court in Laredo, the clerk's office in San Antonio, but nobody could figure out why a judge-- a judge who was no longer there-- had closed the case.
之所以可笑，是因为他还在拘留中，这本身就是证明。但书记员没有任何记录。问题在于，如果案件被正式结案，要获得法庭的任何释放令，保拉需要重新开启案件。她尝试了ICE、拉雷多法庭、圣安东尼奥书记员办公室，但没有人能弄明白为什么一位已经不在那里的法官会结案。
Everyone was baffled, but everyone was also passing the buck. The man sat in detention in Laredo month after month. For any court, this is about as bad as it gets. The government was detaining this man, but legally, the court had no basis to hold him. And still there was no way to get him out because the case was closed. Finally, the immigrant solved the problem himself. ICE brought him a deportation order and he signed it.
每个人都感到困惑，但每个人也都在推卸责任。那名男子在拉雷多的拘留中心坐了几个月又几个月。对任何法庭来说，这都算得上是最糟糕的情况了。政府在拘留这个人，但从法律上讲，法庭没有关押他的依据。但因为案件已经结案，还是没法让他出来。最后，这名移民自己解决了问题。ICE给他带去了一份驱逐令，他签了名。
He just gave up.
他放弃了。
He just gave up. Exactly. He said, no, they just brought me the documents. I signed them. I want out of here. I want to go. I can't do this anymore.
他放弃了。没错。他说，不，他们只是带给了我文件。我签了。我想要离开这里。我想要走。我再也受不了了。
Welcome to the automated case information hotline.
欢迎拨打自动案件信息热线。
This wasn't an isolated incident. On the day we were there, Paola had another case just like it, a client who was in detention. She worried that he would despair and self-deport, as well. Paola called the hotline you can dial in to check the status of any case. She pressed a few buttons, and we got an update on her current client.
这不是孤立事件。我们去的那天，保拉还有另一个类似的案子，客户也在拘留中。她担心他也会绝望并选择自动驱逐。保拉拨打了可以查看任何案件状态的热线。她按了几个键，我们得到了她当前客户的最新情况。
The immigration judge closed proceedings on your case at Laredo SPC 4702 East Saunders, Laredo, Texas, 78041 on August 23, 2017.
移民法官已于2017年8月23日在得克萨斯州拉雷多东桑德斯4702号拉雷多拘留中心结束了您的案件诉讼。
The hotline says his case was closed on August 23, 2017. That was months ago, but he was still in detention, still in need of a hearing to get his case moving-- a hearing he can't get because his case is closed. The system does not contain any information regarding a future hearing date on your case.
热线显示他的案件已于2017年8月23日结案。那已经是几个月前的事了，但他仍被拘留，仍然需要听证会来推进他的案子——他无法获得听证会，因为他的案子已经结案了。系统没有任何关于您案件未来听证日期的信息。
Paola's client, he's in total limbo.
保拉的客户，他处于完全的悬浮状态。
He just sounds defeated. He just says, I just don't want to be sitting here waiting for nothing. If I'm waiting for something, if you tell me I have a court in two months, then I'll wait for that court in two months. But there's no court for me. So the question of the day here is, if we would be in another court, would this still be happening? Or is it just because we're here in Laredo and we're in an immigration court, which is-- it's not organized? Or who is there to blame here if there's someone to blame?
他听起来完全被打败了。他只是说，我只是不想坐在那里什么也不等。如果我是在等什么，如果你告诉我两个月后有听证会，那我会等那两个月后的听证会。但我根本没听证会。所以今天的问题是，如果我们是在另一个法庭，这还会发生吗？还是仅仅因为我们在拉雷多，在移民法庭，而这里组织混乱？或者如果有人该负责的话，该责怪谁？
Did you just put air quotes around "immigration court?"
你刚才给“移民法庭”打引号了吗？
[LAUGHS] Yes. It's crazy. You wouldn't think this would be happening.
[笑] 是的。这太疯狂了。你不会想到会发生这种事。
Your question of would this be happening in another court, what do you think?
关于这在另一个法庭是否会发生的问题，你怎么看？
I highly doubt this would be happening in another court.
我非常怀疑这会在另一个法庭发生。
A day after we recorded this interview, this second client of Paola's was suddenly released, and he didn't even have to post bond. ICE gave no explanation why they let him go.
在我们录完这次采访的一天后，保拉的这位第二位客户突然被释放了，而且他甚至不需要缴纳保释金。ICE没有给出释放他的理由。
Back at the courtroom, at one point, Judge Pettinato looks at the stack of blue files in front of him and whispers to his clerk, "the problem is, I can't do all of these." In fact, the immigration court system is drowning in cases. There's a huge backlog-- at last count, 650,000 cases waiting to be resolved. That number doubled in the last five years under President Obama. 650,000 cases works out to be about 2,000 for every judge, so immigrants often wait several years to have their cases heard.
回到法庭，在某一时刻，佩蒂纳托法官看着面前那堆蓝色文件，对着他的书记员低声说：“问题是我处理不了所有这些。”事实上，移民法庭系统正淹没在案件中。存在巨大的积压——据最新统计，有65万起案件等待解决。在奥巴马总统任内，这个数字在过去五年里翻了一番。65万起案件平均下来每位法官要处理大约2000起，所以移民往往要等几年才能听到他们的案子。
The Trump administration's plan to rush judges to the border was supposed to help with the backlog. If they could quickly turn away illegal border crossers, they could keep new cases from building up in the system. But sending a judge down to a border court for two weeks means that all the cases that were ready to go on their home docket have to be postponed and rescheduled. On Judge Pettinato's Charlotte docket, for example, because of how behind they are there, the cases he had scheduled for the two weeks he was in Laredo had to be reset to late 2018, about a year away. In practice, the backlog in Charlotte just got bigger.
特朗普政府派遣法官到边境的计划本应有助于缓解积压。如果他们能迅速拒绝非法越境者，他们就能阻止新案件在系统中积累。但派遣一名法官到边境法庭两周，意味着在他家乡法庭已经准备好审理的所有案件都必须推迟并重新安排。例如，以佩蒂纳托法官在夏洛特的审理进度为例，由于他们进度落后，他在拉雷多待的两周内原本安排的案件不得不被重排到2018年底，大约一年后。实际上，夏洛特的积压反而增加了。
The thing is, not all the courts with these temporary judges look like Laredo. Some of the border courts have the opposite problem. They have more judges than they need, so judges have ended up sitting around in empty courtrooms with nothing to do. We talked to a judge named Lawrence Burman, who normally sits in a court in Arlington, Virginia. His first border detail was to a court in Jena, Louisiana.
问题是，并非所有拥有这些临时法官的法庭看起来都像拉雷多。一些边境法庭有相反的问题。他们的法官多于需求，因此法官最终只能无所事事地坐在空荡荡的法庭里。我们采访了一位名叫劳伦斯·伯曼的法官，他通常在弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的法庭任职。他的第一次边境任务是去路易斯安那州耶拿的一个法庭。
The problem was that we had four judges there, and there was really only enough work for two judges. So I had a lot of free time, which is pretty useless in Jena, Louisiana. I couldn't really do anything except review the other files for Jena. And once I reviewed all of them, read the newspaper OR read my email.
问题是我们那里有四名法官，而实际上工作只够两名法官做。所以我有很多空闲时间，这在耶拿简直毫无用处。除了查看耶拿的其他档案，我什么也做不了。一旦我查看完所有档案，就只能看报纸或看我的电子邮件。
Out of 10 court days in Jena, there were two days where Judge Burman had no cases at all. Meanwhile, back home, he could have been moving forward with as many as 50 cases a day. Instead, dozens of those cases were rescheduled to the next date he had available on his calendar, which, because of the enormous backlog in Arlington, is three years away, in 2020.
在耶拿的10个开庭日中，有两天伯曼法官根本没有案件。与此同时，在家里，他本可以每天推进多达50起案件。相反，其中的几十起案件被重新安排到他在日历上可用的下一个日期，由于阿灵顿积压严重，那是三年后的2020年。
A sitting federal judge isn't allowed to do an interview. That's why you're not hearing from Judge Pettinato. But Judge Burman is also a high-ranking official with the National Association of Immigration Judges-- it's kind of like their union-- so he can talk to reporters in that capacity.
在职联邦法官不允许接受采访。这就是为什么你听不到佩蒂纳托法官的讲话。但伯曼法官也是全国移民法官协会的高级官员——有点像他们的工会——所以他可以以那个身份与记者交谈。
And before we move on, Judge Burman wanted to make it clear. What he's saying here, these are his views and things he's heard from other judges across the country. They are not the views of the Justice Department or the court system.
在继续之前，伯曼法官想澄清一点。他在这里所说的是他个人的观点以及他从全国其他法官那里听到的事情。这些不是司法部或法庭系统的观点。
Judge Burman never went to Laredo, but he's talked to other judges who've been there, and he confirmed all the problems we saw. He said Laredo was especially notable because there was never a crisis there in the first place. Prior to President Trump's order, all their cases were being heard by judges in San Antonio via a video system. The system wasn't great, but it was working. All the emergency shuffling did was replace judges in San Antonio hearing cases by video with a live judge in Laredo, which, for a while, left some of the judges in San Antonio with empty dockets.
伯曼法官从没去过拉雷多，但他和其他去过那里的法官谈过，他证实了我们看到的所有问题。他说拉雷多特别引人注目，因为那里从未出现过危机。在特朗普总统的命令之前，他们的所有案件都是由圣安东尼奥的法官通过视频系统审理的。这个系统虽不完美，但运行正常。所有的应急调整只是用拉雷多的现场法官取代了圣安东尼奥通过视频审理案件的法官，这导致圣安东尼奥的一些法官在一段时间内没有案件可审。
So basically, a judge who was already on the border-- San Antonio's not exactly on the border, but it's not too far-- had nothing to do. Another judge was pulled away from his docket and sent down there, presumably just so that they could say that they rushed more judges to the border.
所以基本上，一位已经在边境的法官——圣安东尼奥不算完全在边境，但也不远——没事可做。另一位法官从他的工作清单中被抽调并送到那里，大概只是为了让他们能宣称已经向边境派遣了更多法官。
The "they" in this case is the Justice Department, which is run by Attorney General Jeff Sessions. They are actually the ones who oversee the courts. A peculiarity of the American immigration court system is that it's part of the executive branch, which is why the President can rapidly change the priorities of the court like this.
这里的“他们”是指由司法部长杰夫·塞申斯领导的司法部。实际上是他们监督着法庭。美国移民法庭系统的一个特点是它是行政部门的一部分，这就是为什么总统可以如此迅速地改变法庭的优先事项。
The Department of Justice doesn't really understand what we do and probably don't care very much in the final analysis. It just wants to present to the attorney general the fact that they're doing everything that they can. So I assume that they just sent as many judges to the border as they had courtrooms to put them in without much regard to how many cases there actually were there. It's almost as if the Department of Justice and [INAUDIBLE] management are trying to see how they can make the system less and less efficient.
司法部并没有真正理解我们在做什么，归根结底可能也不怎么关心。它只是想向司法部长展示他们正在尽一切所能的事实。所以我认为他们只是派出了尽可能多的法官到边境，只要有法庭放他们就行，而不太考虑那里到底有多少案件。这简直就像是司法部和管理层在试图看他们能如何让系统变得越来越没有效率。
In the name of efficiency?
以效率的名义？
Well, I don't know what they think they're doing, but what they're doing is not efficient. Just my opinion and opinion of practically every judge that I know.
嗯，我不知道他们认为自己在做什么，但他们做的事情并不高效。这只是我的观点，也是我认识的几乎每一位法官的观点。
Like we said, President Trump's plan for these courts was to process people and deport them quickly. And during our week in Laredo, we did see some bad hombres come through the court-- immigrants who'd gotten involved in drug trafficking. There was one Mexican who worked with a human smuggling ring, harboring other undocumented immigrants for $100 a pop.
正如我们所说，特朗普总统对这些法庭的计划是处理并迅速驱逐人员。在我们待在拉雷多的那一周，我们确实看到了一些坏家伙穿过法庭——参与毒品走私的移民。有一名墨西哥人曾与人口走私团伙合作，以每人100美元的价格收容其他非法移民。
But in general, these emergency border courts were designed to handle a crisis at the border that isn't happening. In 2017, Customs and Border Protection recorded the lowest level of illegal migration in 45 years. President Trump made it clear that he was going to be tough on immigrants. And after he won the election, the numbers declined sharply.
但总的来说，这些应急边境法庭旨在处理边境根本没有发生的危机。2017年，海关和边境保护局记录了45年来非法移民的最低水平。特朗普总统明确表示他会对移民强硬。在他赢得大选后，数字急剧下降。
Many immigrants who are coming now are people who we can't deport quickly-- asylum seekers who have a right to have their case heard before an immigration judge. We spent a little time at the border in Laredo. And within just an hour, we saw eight people who had presented themselves to authorities requesting asylum. The numbers that are really way up over the last year are not at the border. They're the rest of immigrants inside the country, in towns and cities that are losing judges for weeks at a time to these border courts.
现在来的许多移民是我们无法迅速驱逐的人——有权在移民法官面前审理其案件的寻求庇护者。我们在拉雷多的边境待了一段时间。仅仅一小时内，我们就看到8人向当局申请庇护。过去一年里真正增加的数字不是在边境，而是在国内其他地方，在那些法官被临时调往边境法庭数周的城镇和城市。
The Trump administration has said they're pleased with the results of this surge of immigration judges, that it's been a success. The director of the Justice Department agency that oversees the immigration courts said, and I quote, "mobilized immigration judges had completed approximately 2,700 more cases than expected if they had not been detailed." Essentially, he argued that judges who were sent to the border, about 100 of them in all, they completed 2,700 more cases than they would have if they'd stayed in their home courts. But that doesn't take into account that sending judges to the border meant that at least 22,000 cases around the country had to be rescheduled in the first three months alone-- perhaps for a year, as in Judge Pettinato's Charlotte cases, or perhaps three years, like in Judge Burman's courtroom.
特朗普政府表示，他们对这次移民法官激增的结果感到满意，认为这是成功的。监督移民法庭的司法部机构主管说，我引用：“动员后的移民法官比没有派遣他们时多处理了大约2700起案件。”本质上，他辩称，被送往边境的约100名法官，比他们留在国内法庭时多完成了2700起案件。但这没有考虑到，向边境派遣法官意味着仅在前三个月，全国至少有2.2万起案件必须重新安排——可能像佩蒂纳托法官在夏洛特的案件一样推迟一年，或者像在伯曼法官的法庭一样推迟三年。
We reached out to the Justice Department for comment. They didn't respond to our request for an interview, but they did answer some questions over email. An official stressed that the backlog in immigration court is getting better. To be clear, they haven't actually reduced the backlog. It's still increasing. But they point out that it's increasing at a slower rate. It was growing at over 3% per month when President Trump took office, and it's less than 0.5% now. But it's unclear if this change was because the Justice Department sent judges to the border or because of other efforts they've made to reduce the backlog, like hiring dozens of immigration judges.
我们联系了司法部请其置评。他们没有回复我们的采访请求，但他们确实通过电子邮件回答了一些问题。一位官员强调，移民法庭的积压情况正在好转。需要明确的是，他们并没有真正减少积压。它仍在增加。但他们指出增加的速度变慢了。特朗普总统上任时，积压每月增长超过3%，现在不到0.5%。但目前尚不清楚这种变化是因为司法部派遣法官到边境，还是因为他们为减少积压所做的其他努力，比如聘请了数十名移民法官。
There was one other fact they wouldn't explain. Unceremoniously, at the end of last year, the Justice Department decided to stop sending judges to Laredo. They went back to the old video system. We asked them why that decision was made and got no response.
还有一个他们拒绝解释的事实。去年年底，司法部在毫无预兆的情况下，决定停止派遣法官到拉雷多。他们回到了旧的视频系统。我们问他们为什么要做出这个决定，但没有得到任何回应。
Our last morning in Laredo, we saw a case that told us a lot about many of the immigrants who were being deported by this court. It was a hearing for an undocumented Mexican man named Fernando. He wasn't a recent border crosser. He had no criminal record, so he wasn't a priority for deportation, even for the Trump administration, which says it's focusing on getting rid of criminals.
在拉雷多的最后一个早晨，我们看到了一个案子，它揭示了这个法庭驱逐的许多移民的情况。这是一名名叫费尔南多的非法墨西哥男子的听证会。他不是最近的越境者。他没有犯罪记录，所以即使对特朗普政府来说，他也不是驱逐的优先对象，因为政府声称专注于清除罪犯。
We met his girlfriend, Irma, in the waiting room. She said together they were raising four children, all American citizens born here. Fernando had been picked up by local police after getting into a loud argument outside a Laredo bar. He wasn't charged or convicted of anything, but the cops turned him over to ICE.
我们在候诊室见到了他的女友伊尔玛。她说他们一起抚养四个孩子，全都是在这里出生的美国公民。费尔南多在拉雷多一家酒吧外发生大声争吵后被当地警察带走。他没有被指控或被定罪，但警察把他移交给了ICE。
But when Fernando started laying out all the details of his story-- this was just a few minutes into his case-- Judge Pettinato interrupted him. "Sir, I've got a whole bunch of cases going on today. I get the gist." The judge was ready to issue his decision. Fernando would have to leave the country.
但当费尔南多开始陈述他故事的所有细节时——那只是他案件开始几分钟后——佩蒂纳托法官打断了他。“先生，我今天还有一大堆案子要审。我明白大意了。”法官准备发布他的决定。费尔南多将不得不离开这个国家。
He and his girlfriend looked stunned. Fernando choked up. He kept putting his head in his hands and staring at the wall. It was pretty clear he and Irma hadn't expected a decision. They thought this was just going to be a procedural hearing and they'd have time to get a lawyer. In fact, in a regular immigration court, that's exactly what would have happened. I've seen it many times. But now Fernando wouldn't get a chance to fully tell his story to a judge.
他和他的女友看起来惊呆了。费尔南多哽咽了。他不停地把头埋在手里，盯着墙看。很明显，他和伊尔玛没想到会这么快出决定。他们以为这只是一个程序性的听证会，他们还有时间去找律师。事实上，在正常的移民法庭，那正是会发生的事情。我见过很多次。但现在，费尔南多将没有机会完整地向法官讲述他的故事。
These border courts are designed for speed. That's their whole point. And this is what that looks like. Judge Pettinato took a moment to explain to Fernando that, even though it was commendable that he wanted to stay in the US to help his family, legally, there was no way he could allow it. That same afternoon, Fernando was put on the bridge to Nuevo Laredo, Mexico.
这些边境法庭是为了速度而设计的。这就是它们的全部意义所在。这就是实际情况。佩蒂纳托法官花了一点时间向费尔南多解释，尽管他想留在美国帮助家人的愿望值得称赞，但从法律上讲，他无法允许这样做。当天下午，费尔南多就被送上了前往墨西哥新拉雷多的桥梁。
Julia Preston and our producer, Jonathan Menjivar. That story was produced in collaboration with The Marshall Project, where Julia's a contributing writer. The Marshall Project does in-depth reporting on the criminal justice system. You can read the print version of Julia's story at themarshallproject.org.
朱莉娅·普雷斯顿和我们的制片人乔纳森·门吉瓦尔。该报道是与“马歇尔计划”合作制作的，朱莉娅是该计划的特约撰稿人。“马歇尔计划”对刑事司法系统进行深入报道。你可以在themarshallproject.org阅读朱莉娅报道的印刷版。
Coming up. OK, we and our staff truly did not understand what's happening with the Democratic Party, and we spent a few months trying to figure it out. What we learned in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来。好吧，我们和我们的员工真的不明白民主党发生了什么，我们花了几个月试图弄清楚。我们学到了什么，一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共电台的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, I Thought It Would Be Easier, stories about how difficult it seems to be lately for politicians to get things done, even things that seem pretty straightforward. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Fighting Amongst Demselves.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《我以为会更容易》，关于最近政客们完成事情看起来有多难的故事，即使是那些看起来相当直截了当的事情。我们已经到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，民主党内斗。
So one of the most basic things a political party is supposed to do is stand for something and articulate it. And a few months into Donald Trump's presidency, the questions, what does the Democratic Party stand for? What are they doing? What is the strategy? They've grown so large that it had the power to render grown people speechless.
政党应该做的一件最基本的事情就是代表某种立场并将其阐明。在唐纳德·特朗普总统任期几个月后，民主党代表什么？他们在做什么？战略是什么？这些问题变得如此之大，以至于它有能力让成年人哑口无言。
The Democratic Party, um, is-- is--
民主党，呃，是——是——
Arguably, the national headquarters for impatience with the Democrats is the studios of MSNBC. Here's one of their anchors, Joe Scarborough.
可以说，对民主党不耐烦的全国大本营是MSNBC的演播室。这是他们的主播之一，乔·斯卡伯勒。
I'm talking about the national party is clueless. Where is the Democratic Party? Mika, where are the Democrats?
我说的是全国政党一窍不通。民主党在哪？米卡，民主党人在哪？
I'm praying.
我在祈祷。
No, no, I'm dead serious.
不，不，我说真的。
No, I'm serious, too.
不，我也很认真。
What has happened to this party?
这个党发生了什么？
The Democrats have lost over 1,000 state legislative seats over the past eight years. They've lost the White House to a guy who nobody would even hire as their CEO. They've lost over a dozen Senate seats. They've lost over 60 House seats over the past eight years. And the Democrats still don't know who they are. What is wrong with this party?
过去八年里，民主党失去了超过1000个州立法席位。他们把白宫输给了一个没人会雇来当CEO的家伙。他们失去了十多个参议院席位。过去八年里，他们失去了超过60个众议院席位。而民主党人仍然不知道他们是谁。这个党到底出了什么问题？
One of our producers, Ben Calhoun, traveled around, interviewing Democratic strategists and politicians this summer and fall, trying to understand why there did not seem to be a coherent strategy or message. Here's Ben.
我们的制片人之一，本·卡尔霍恩，今年夏天和秋天四处奔波，采访了民主党战略家和政客，试图理解为什么他们似乎没有连贯的战略或信息。这是本。
It's one thing for Joe Scarborough, who exists in a state of suspended exasperation, to be rolling his eyes at the Democrats. It's a completely different thing for someone like Ken Martin to feel fed up. Ken Martin's one of the country's top Democrats. He runs the Minnesota Democratic Party, and he leads the association of all the state Democratic Parties across the country. And he's the vice chair of the DNC.
对于斯卡伯勒来说，处于持续的恼火状态对民主党翻白眼是一回事。对于像肯·马丁这样的人感到受够了则是完全另一回事。肯·马丁是全国顶级民主党人之一。他运营明尼苏达州民主党，并领导全国所有州民主党协会。他还是民主党全国委员会的副主席。
Our brand is [BLEEP]. Our brand is toxic. People don't know what the heck it is. If you got 100 Democrats in this room right now and asked them what the Democratic Party stands for, you'd get 100 different answers. There's no consistency. No one knows what the Democratic Party is. If you got 100 Republicans in here, by and large, you would get at least some consistency on what their party stands for. People need to have some clarity as to who the Democratic Party is, why we do what we do, why we care, and what we're fighting for.
我们的品牌是[脏话]。我们的品牌是有毒的。人们根本不知道那是什么鬼。如果你现在在这个房间里有100个民主党人，问他们民主党代表什么，你会得到100个不同的答案。没有一致性。没人知道民主党是什么。如果你在这里有100个共和党人，总的来说，你至少会在他们的党代表什么上得到一些一致性。人们需要明确民主党是谁，为什么我们这样做，为什么我们在乎，以及我们为什么而战。
How anxious are you feeling about this moment?
你对这一刻感到多焦虑？
Well, I feel very anxious. I feel, for the Democratic Party, this is an existential moment.
嗯，我感到非常焦虑。我觉得，对于民主党来说，这是一个存亡时刻。
But what exactly might people have been expecting from Democrats in the first year of the Trump era? To that question, I would offer what the Republicans did when Barack Obama was elected. They were at their lowest point in decades. They'd lost both houses of Congress and the Presidency. There's a story about that moment that's been documented by a bunch of places, best by reporter Robert Draper.
但人们在特朗普时代的第一年里到底可能对民主党有什么期待？对于这个问题，我会提出共和党在贝拉克·奥巴马当选时所做的事情。他们处于几十年来最低的低谷。他们失去了国会两院和总统职位。关于那一刻，有一个被许多地方记录下来的故事，最好的是由记者罗伯特·德雷珀记录的。
On the night of Obama's inauguration, a bunch of Republicans go out for dinner at a fancy steakhouse, a place called The Caucus Room. It's a powerful bunch. You've got Paul Ryan, Kevin McCarthy, Eric Cantor, Bob Corker, Frank Luntz, Newt Gingrich, more than a dozen people. And as Obama is visiting inaugural balls, this group sets a strategy. They would oppose and attack every idea Obama had. "If he was for it, we had to be against it," is how one senator put it. One key to this whole thing was that they all had to commit to the same plan. Paul Ryan, then a young congressman from Wisconsin, told the group, "the only way we succeed is if we're united."
在奥巴马就职典礼的那天晚上，一群共和党人去一家高档牛排馆吃饭，一个叫“核心小组厅”的地方。这是一群有权势的人。有保罗·瑞安、凯文·麦卡锡、埃里克·坎托、鲍勃·科克、弗兰克·伦茨、纽特·金里奇，十几个人以上。当奥巴马出席就职舞会时，这群人制定了一个战略。他们将反对并攻击奥巴马的所有想法。“如果他支持它，我们就必须反对它，”一位参议员这样说。整件事的一个关键是他们都必须致力于同一个计划。时任威斯康星州年轻国会议员的保罗·瑞安告诉这群人：“我们成功的唯一途径就是团结一致。”
I think that story is amazing because it's exactly what they did. It's like staring at the source code for eight years of Republican politics. And you can trace the path of that strategy from that steakhouse, through their opposition to the stimulus and Obamacare and everything else, through Republicans retaking Congress and the White House.
我觉得那个故事很棒，因为这正是他们所做的。这就像盯着共和党政治八年的源代码。你可以追踪那个战略的路径，从那个牛排馆开始，经过他们对刺激方案和奥巴马医改以及其他一切的反对，通过共和党重新夺回国会和白宫。
If Democrats had a meeting like this, in a steakhouse or anywhere, they did not walk out with a strategy that everyone is now following, right? A year into the Trump presidency, sure, the Democrats were united against the president's tax cuts and his attempts to repeal Obamacare, but beyond that, they do not have a clear message or strategy. And one of the big reasons-- they just don't agree. They don't agree about who they are, or what the party should be, or what they should be saying.
如果民主党在牛排馆或任何地方开了这样的会议，他们并没有带着每个人现在都在遵循的战略走出来，对吧？特朗普执政一年后，当然，民主党人团结一致反对总统的减税政策和废除奥巴马医改的尝试，但除此之外，他们没有清晰的信息或战略。最大的原因之一是——他们根本不一致。他们不同意他们是谁，或者该党应该是什么，或者他们应该说什么。
And no one has the power to say, here's where we're going. In fact, when Democratic leadership sends out talking points, congressional staffers have told me they're taken more as suggestions and regularly ignored. Several Democrats told me they felt a little jealous of the discipline of the Republican messaging operation.
没有人有权力说，我们要去这里。事实上，当民主党领导层发出谈话要点时，国会工作人员告诉我，这些更多是被视为建议，并经常被忽视。几位民主党人告诉我，他们对共和党信息操作的纪律性感到有点嫉妒。
And the Democrats aren't even in agreement about what went wrong in 2016. In the early months of the Trump presidency, Democrats were still picking that apart, trying to figure out what went so badly and searching for anything-- anything-- that had gone well. One place it felt like they might find hope was with a small list of congressional districts, which a few staffers had started calling the Trump 12.
民主党人甚至对2016年出了什么问题都没有共识。在特朗普总统任期的头几个月里，民主党人仍在拆解那个问题，试图弄清楚什么地方出了大错，并寻找任何——任何——进展顺利的事情。有一个地方让他们觉得可能会找到希望，那就是一份小的国会选区名单，一些工作人员开始称之为“特朗普12选区”。
The Trump 12 were 12 congressional districts where Democratic congressional reps had won, even though Donald Trump had also won there. Most of them were in the Midwest and Pennsylvania, states that were pivotal for Trump. In hindsight, it seemed like Democrats who had held Trump back in those areas might have answers on how to reach white, working-class voters, rural white, working-class voters who'd abandoned the Democrats, which that's what led me to Cheri Bustos.
“特朗普12选区”是12个国会选区，尽管唐纳德·特朗普也赢得了那里，但民主党国会代表却赢了。他们大多数在美中和宾夕法尼亚州，这对特朗普至关重要的州。事后看来，那些在这些地区遏制住特朗普的民主党人似乎对如何争取白人、工人阶级选民，那些抛弃了民主党的农村白人、工人阶级选民有答案，这让我找到了切里·布斯托斯。
Cheri Bustos is one of the Trump 12. She represents a district that covers the northwest corner of Illinois. It's mostly rural, heavily white, home of John Deere. Caterpillar Manufacturing started there. Last fall, Trump won in Bustos' district. But Bustos also won reelection by a 20-point landslide.
切里·布斯托斯是“特朗普12选区”的一员。她代表的选区覆盖伊利诺伊州西北角。这里主要是农村，白人占多数，是约翰迪尔的故乡。卡特彼勒制造公司从那里开始。去年秋天，特朗普赢得了布斯托斯的选区。但布斯托斯也以20个百分点的压倒性优势赢得了连任。
In May, Politico wrote a profile with the headline "The Secret Weapon Democrats Don't Know How to Use." The article's question-- Cheri Bustos has lessons about how to win in Trump territory, but are Democrats listening? They were.
五月，Politico写了一篇题为“民主党不知道如何使用的秘密武器”的简介。文章的问题是——切里·布斯托斯有关于如何在特朗普领土上获胜的经验教训，但民主党人在听吗？他们听了。
She was chosen to co-chair the policy and communications committee in the House, three members who lead strategy and messaging for congressional Democrats. The Democratic Congressional Campaign Committee created a new position for her-- Chairwoman of Heartland Engagement, which, as someone from Wisconsin, can I just say nobody in the Midwest walks around talking about the Heartland. Also, like Democrats need to send an ambassador to part of their own country? Whatever.
她被选为众议院政策和通信委员会的联合主席，这是指导国会民主党战略和信息的三个成员。民主党国会竞选委员会为她设立了一个新职位——心脏地带参与主席，作为一个来自威斯康星州的人，我可以直说吗？没人在美中走来走去谈论什么心脏地带。而且，民主党人需要派一位大使去他们自己国家的某个地方吗？随便吧。
In late June, I went to see Bustos in Illinois to ask her about the party and what she thinks it should be doing.
六月下旬，我去伊利诺伊州见了布斯托斯，问她关于该党以及她认为该党应该做什么。
Gosh, what a great turnout.
天哪，多棒的出席人数。
I caught up with Bustos at a union hall, one of these events she's been having called Build the Bench, where she tries to recruit and train people to run as Democrats, to create a farm team, something Democrats acknowledge they have not done a good job with lately.
我在一个工会大厅追上了布斯托斯，这是她举办的名为“建设基石”的活动之一，在那里她试图招募和培训人们作为民主党人竞选，建立一个后备梯队，这是民主党人承认最近没做得很好的事情。
You're not going to say, will you please give me $20. If somebody's got a decent job, you're going to say, can you make $1,000 contribution?
你不能说，你能给我20美元吗？如果某人有一份不错的工作，你会说，你能捐款1000美元吗？
It's interesting to watch regular people encountering the less glamorous realities of running for office for the first time. It's kind of like they're seeing the back door to a restaurant. At one point, Bustos was talking to a woman who was thinking about running. The woman had shared a bio with Bustos. It explained she'd graduated top 10 in her college class.
观看普通人第一次接触竞选公职那些不太光鲜的现实是很有趣的。有点像他们在看一家餐馆的后门。在某一时刻，布斯托斯正在同一个考虑参选的妇女交谈。这位妇女和布斯托斯分享了一份简历。上面解释说她在大学班级里排名前10。
So a couple things. You've got a very good personal story. And it's great that you were 10th in your class, but people don't want to know that you're smart. And most people in our region are not college educated.
所以有几件事。你有一个非常好的个人故事。你班级排名前10这很好，但人们不想知道你很聪明。我们地区的多数人都没有受过大学教育。
When I ran for city council, I had what my bio was, and I had where I went to college. And I literally had somebody say, what? Do you think you're better than we are? I'm like, what do you mean? He's like, well, so you went to college. You think that's a big deal? So find a way to connect with people, and that's going to be your dad was a factory worker. You're the granddaughter of a farmer. Talk about how you can meet people where they are.
当我竞选市议会时，我也有简历，我也写了我去哪里上大学。然后我真的有人说，什么？你以为你比我们好吗？我说，什么意思？他说，嗯，所以你上过大学。你以为那是什么大事吗？所以想办法和人们建立联系，那就会是你爸爸是工厂工人。你是农民的孙女。谈谈你如何能在人们所在的地方与他们会面。
Meet voters where they are. This is Bustos' core philosophy, her vision for what the party should be doing. In person, Bustos looks like a former college athlete, which she is, talks like a former health care executive, which she is, and compulsively parents like a mother of three, which she is. She's the only person who's asked me as an adult if I need to go to the bathroom before getting in a car.
在选民所在的地方与他们会面。这是布斯托斯的核心哲学，她对该党应该做什么的愿景。在现实中，布斯托斯看起来像一位前大学运动员，她也确实是，说话像一位前医疗保健高管，她也确实是，并且像三个孩子的母亲一样强迫性地像个家长，她也确实是。她是唯一一个在我成年后，在进入车里前问我是否需要上厕所的人。
After a while, Bustos and I sat down away from everybody else.
过了一会儿，布斯托斯和我坐在远离其他人的地方。
I don't think we, as Democrats, will fail if, number one, we start talking about jobs and the economy nonstop. That's, in my opinion as a Democrat, is what we need to do. The divisive issues that are out there-- I don't know why we would walk into a room and start with a divisive issue.
我认为我们作为民主党人不会失败，如果，第一，我们开始不停地谈论就业和经济。作为一名民主党人，我认为这就是我们需要做的。那些存在的分歧问题——我不明白为什么我们会走进一个房间并从一个分歧问题开始。
I don't go into a room and start my conversation by talking about the fact that I'm pro-choice, talking about guns, one way or another, because those are issues that tend to divide. But I do go into a room and I talk about my fight for good jobs, for better wages, better skills, and better jobs. That is what we are fighting for everyday as Democrats. So now, if somebody asked me my views on issues that are more divisive, I'll answer it honestly, and then I'll get back to talking about jobs and the economy.
我不走进一个房间并从谈论我支持堕胎选择权、谈论枪支，这样或那样开始对话，因为那些往往会造成分歧。但我走进一个房间，谈论我为好工作、为更好的工资、更好的技能和更好的工作而奋斗。这就是我们作为民主党人每天为之奋斗的目标。所以现在，如果有人问我对那些分歧较大问题的看法，我会诚实回答，然后我会回到谈论就业和经济的话题上。
I spent a lot of hours with Cheri Bustos at this point. And if I had to write her strategy for the Democrats on a napkin, it'd go like this. Congressional districts are so gerrymandered-- so many are solidly Democrat or solidly Republican-- that there are very few real swing districts like hers. And Bustos says voters in those districts are moderate. If the national party moves too far to the left, you know, Black Lives Matter, or immigrants' rights, or universal health care, well yeah, it will fire up people in big blue cities and on the coasts. But Democrats already have those votes. In the districts they need, districts like hers, the ones they have to win, she says that will do you in. So as a practical matter, keeping it centrist and moderate, that's the path to win back Congress and the presidency.
此时此刻，我和切里·布斯托斯相处了很多小时。如果我必须在餐巾纸上为民主党写下她的战略，它会是这样的：国会选区被重划得太严重了——很多选区是铁杆民主党或铁杆共和党——以至于像她这样的真正摇摆选区很少。布斯托斯说，那些选区的选民是温和派。如果全国政党向左走得太远，你知道，黑人的命也是命，或者移民权利，或者全民医保，好吧，是的，它会点燃大蓝市和沿海地区的人。但民主党已经有了那些票。在他们需要的选区，像她这样的选区，他们必须赢得的选区，她说那样做会毁了你。所以作为实际问题，保持中间派和温和派，那是赢回国会和总统职位的途径。
And plenty of Democrats are with Bustos on that. The strategy isn't new. Targeting moderates and centrist voters, that's been the Democrats' playbook since Bill Clinton. But in 2018, it is remarkable, I think, not for what it is, but for what it leaves out. For starters, consider the most popular working politician in either party right now.
而且很多民主党人都支持布斯托斯。这个战略并不新鲜。瞄准中间派和温和派选民，那是民主党自比尔·克林顿以来的剧本。但在2018年，我觉得这很引人注目，不是因为它是什么，而是因为它遗漏了什么。首先，考虑一下现在两党中工作中最受欢迎的政客。
Bernie! Bernie! Bernie! Bernie!
伯尼！伯尼！伯尼！伯尼！
Over the summer, following the defeat of the Republican repeal of Obamacare, Senator Bernie Sanders went on the offensive in a very non-Cheri Bustos way. He did a tour that was all about universal health care, progressive style, Sweden-worshipping, single-payer health care.
夏天，在共和党废除奥巴马医改失败后，伯尼·桑德斯参议员以一种非常不切里·布斯托斯的方式发起了进攻。他进行了一次巡回演讲，全部关于全民医保，进步风格，崇拜瑞典的单一付款人医保。
If Canada can do it, if Europe can do it, if Scandinavia can do it, we can do it in the United States. Health care is a right, not a privilege.
如果加拿大能做到，如果欧洲能做到，如果斯堪的纳维亚能做到，我们也能在美国做到。医疗是权利，不是特权。
Sanders repeatedly drew crowds in the thousands in Democratic areas, but also deep red ones. Meanwhile, leftist activism surged in the wake of the Women's March from groups like Indivisible and Swing Left, to the whole assortment of Black Lives Matter groups, to protesters at airports all across the country.
桑德斯在民主党地区，但也包括深红地区，多次吸引了数千人参加。与此同时，左翼行动主义在“妇女游行”后激增，从Indivisible和Swing Left等团体，到各种黑人的命也是命团体，再到全国各机场的抗议者。
It is my honor to introduce to you the Congressman from Minnesota, Congressman Keith Ellison.
很荣幸向大家介绍来自明尼苏达州的国会议员，基思·埃里森议员。
When I started following Cheri Bustos around, I also started following Keith Ellison. Ellison's a congressman from Minnesota. He's black, the first Muslim elected to Congress. He used to chair the Progressive Caucus in the House. He ran and lost for DNC chair, but he took the number two job running the DNC-- deputy chair. This was Ellison talking to the Democratic Party of Vermont last year.
当我开始跟踪切里·布斯托斯时，我也开始跟踪基思·埃里森。埃里森是明尼苏达州的国会议员。他是黑人，是第一个当选国会议员的穆斯林。他曾经主持众议院的进步党团。他竞选民主党全国委员会主席失败了，但他担任了运营民主党全国委员会的二号职位——副主席。这是埃里森去年对佛蒙特州民主党人所说的话。
The Republican Party is the party that wants to ban the Muslims and wall the Mexicans. It wants to keep transgender people from going to the bathroom. The Republican Party under Trump and Trumpism is the party that says that liberty and justice for all, except Muslims, Mexicans, you know, fill in the blank, right? The Democratic Party has to be the sharp edge, the pointy edge of saying liberty and justice for all. We don't care, man. These are our people, and we embrace them.
共和党是那个想要禁止穆斯林并给墨西哥人筑墙的党。它想要阻止跨性别者使用厕所。特朗普和特朗普主义下的共和党是那个说人人享有自由和公正，除了穆斯林、墨西哥人，你知道，填空，对吧？民主党必须是尖锐的、尖锐的边际，说人人享有自由和公正。我们不在乎，伙计。这些人是我们的人民，我们拥抱他们。
That night, Ellison talked about transgender rights, gay rights, undocumented immigrants, Muslims, sexual harassment, pay inequity, single-payer health care. And he specifically talked about the issue of race, how he felt that it was being used to divide the country. He talked about Charlottesville, about the President and Republicans condoning racism. Rather than trying to avoid an issue like race because it was hot, he gave a speech that drove right at it for that very reason.
那天晚上，埃里森谈到了跨性别权利、同性恋权利、非法移民、穆斯林、性骚扰、薪酬不平等、单一付款人医保。他特别谈到了种族问题，谈到了他如何感到种族被用来分裂国家。他谈到了夏洛茨维尔，谈到了总统和共和党人纵容种族主义。他没有试图回避像种族这样热门的问题，而是发表了一场直接针对它的演讲，正是因为这个原因。
We have got to be that vanguard. We have got to be that righteous group of people who never stop fighting for equality, who believe that the best of our country is yet to come, and that genius is not tied up in any ethnic group, but is in all ethnic groups. This is what we have to stand for.
我们必须成为那个先锋。我们必须成为那个始终为平等而战、相信我们国家最好的未来尚未到来、天才不被任何族裔群体所束缚，而是存在于所有族裔群体中的正义群体。这就是我们必须代表的。
If I were to try to summarize Keith Ellison's argument for the party on a napkin, it might go like this. We are in an extreme moment. Wealth in America hasn't been so unequally skewed since the 1920s. And people feel stuck and ground down, and they're mad. And so they don't want the usual political talk. They want people who recognize how messed up things are and who are riled up too, and who won't shy away from conflict, who are going to propose things that are aggressive and bold.
如果我试图在餐巾纸上总结埃里森对该党的论点，它可能是这样的：我们处于一个极端时刻。美国的财富分配不均程度是1920年代以来最严重的。人们感到被困住并被磨平，他们很生气。所以他们不想要通常的政治谈话。他们想要那些认识到事情有多糟糕、同样感到愤怒、不会回避冲突、准备提出积极和大胆方案的人。
You're hearing one group of Democrats say, we need bold ideas that are going to solve your problem. And you hear another say, well, uh, we don't need so much bold ideas. We just need to, you know, just keep it real, tame. And we don't want to offend anybody. We don't want to upset the Republicans.
你听到一群民主党人说，我们需要能解决你问题的勇敢想法。你听到另一群人说，嗯，呃，我们不需要那么多勇敢想法。我们只需要，你知道，保持真实，温和点。我们不想冒犯任何人。我们不想让共和党人不安。
You're going to be confronted with a choice. And you're going to say, I think one of the two groups is right. I think people are going to say that the bold ideas people are right. And most Democrats are going to understand that just incremental, tepid solutions to the deep, serious problems people are facing, it's just not going to be adequate.
你将面临一个选择。你会说，我想两组人中有一组是对的。我想人们会说那些勇敢想法的人是对的。大多数民主党人会明白，对于人们面临的深层、严重问题，仅仅是渐进的、不温不火的解决方案，是不够的。
Progressives like Ellison question the conventional wisdom Democratic strategy of taking blue states for granted, and writing off red states as lost causes, and fighting only for swing districts and swing voters, he says it's hard to build a national party when you leave most people feeling ignored. Ellison calls all of that a minimalist strategy designed to fail. Like other progressives, he points to Hillary Clinton. That was her strategy.
像埃里森这样的进步派质疑民主党将蓝州视为理所当然、将红州注销为失败原因、只为摇摆选区和摇摆选民而战的传统智慧战略。他说当大多数人感到被忽视时，建立全国性政党很难。埃里森称所有这些为旨在失败的极简主义战略。像其他进步派一样，他提到了希拉里·克林顿。那是她的战略。
In an op ed in The New York Times in June, Bernie Sanders reviewed where that strategy has gotten Democrats-- to their lowest point in decades. He wrote, "If these results are not a clear manifestation of a failed political strategy, I don't know what is." Like Ellison, Sanders says Democrats need a strategy that seizes on what's got people worked up and excites them. And that, they say, is how Democrats can rebuild, drive votes, and make a comeback.
在六月《纽约时报》的一篇专栏文章中，伯尼·桑德斯回顾了那个战略把民主党带到了哪里——几十年来最低的低谷。他写道：“如果这些结果不是失败政治战略的明显表现，我不知道什么才是。”像埃里森一样，桑德斯说民主党需要一种战略，抓住人们激动人心的事情并激发他们。而这，他们说，就是民主党人如何重建、推动投票并卷土重来的方式。
So you had these very conflicting views of what the party needed. And eight months after Donald Trump was elected, there was such an absence of an official Democratic message, or strategy, or plan that people started to measure the empty space where one might have been. In July, The Washington Post and ABC News released this poll. It said 52% of Americans felt the only message Democrats had was that they were against Trump. Then finally, Democratic Party leaders stood on the bow of the boat and they pointed in a direction. It felt kind of like, all right, I know you're waiting. OK, OK.
所以你有关于该党需要什么的非常冲突的观点。唐纳德·特朗普当选八个月后，官方的民主党信息、战略或计划的缺失程度如此之大，以至于人们开始衡量原本可能存在的东西的空洞空间。七月，《华盛顿邮报》和ABC新闻发布了这项民意调查。它显示52%的美国人认为民主党唯一的信息就是他们反对特朗普。终于，民主党领导人站在船头，指向了一个方向。感觉像是，好吧，我知道你在等。好吧，好吧。
OK. So good afternoon, Berryville.
好的。那么，下午好，贝里维尔。
On July 24, Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer, House Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi, along with four more senators and four more congressmen, left Washington DC. They drove for an hour out into the country to this small town called Berryville in rural Virginia. Schumer kicked things off. This is how he explained what they were there to do.
7月24日，参议院少数党领袖查克·舒默，众议院少数党领袖南希·佩洛西，连同四位参议员和四位国会议员，离开了华盛顿特区。他们开车一小时进入乡村，前往弗吉尼亚州农村一个叫贝里维尔的小镇。舒默开了个头。这就是他解释他们来这里要做的事情。
Too many Americans don't know what we stand for. Not after today. Now, we know that now we're in the minority in both houses of Congress. We can't delude anyone that this Congress will begin passing our priorities tomorrow. But we have to start presenting our vision for the country's future. This is the start of a new version for the party.
太多美国人不知道我们代表什么。今天之后不再是这样了。现在，我们知道我们现在是国会两院的少数党。我们不能欺骗任何人说这个国会明天就会开始通过我们的优先事项。但我们必须开始展示我们对国家未来的愿景。这是该党新愿景的开始。
So what they proceeded to lay out, the bold, new version of the Democratic Party was a bunch of things you've heard Democrats talk about before. Here were the parts of the plan-- lowering prescription drug costs, infrastructure, job training, anti-trust legislation, raising wages. It was a long list.
所以他们着手提出的，民主党的大胆、新版本，是一堆你以前听过民主党谈论的事情。这是计划的部分内容——降低处方药成本、基础设施、职业培训、反托拉斯立法、提高工资。这是一个长长的名单。
Just the materials explaining it, 10 pages, single-spaced-- it was a lot of ideas, but definitely nothing too edgy or provocative. In that way, it weirdly felt like a message determined by subtraction. It was like a dish cooked up by taking politically-charged ingredients off the table, one by one, until no one would find it too salty or too spicy or too anything.
单是解释它的材料，10页，单行距——这是很多想法，但绝对没什么太前卫或挑衅性的。那样，它奇怪地感觉像是通过减法决定的信息。这就像是一道通过从桌子上一个接一个拿走有政治色彩成分而烹饪出来的菜，直到没人会觉得它太咸或太辣或太什么。
What was surprising was how underwhelming the presentation was-- inoffensive, and yet sometimes tone-deaf. You had all the men, folksy in their rolled-up shirtsleeves, and then Schumer telling a story in the middle of rural Virginia about the Yankees.
令人惊讶的是演示是多么令人扫兴——无冒犯性，但有时又缺乏感觉。你看着所有男人，卷起衬衫袖子显得朴实，然后舒默在弗吉尼亚州农村中间讲述关于扬基队的故事。
Now, last month, I went to a Yankees game.
现在，上个月，我去看了扬基队的比赛。
[LAUGHING AND GROANING]
[笑声和呻吟声]
Just respectful note to the senator. America hates the Yankees. Nancy Pelosi kept the salt of the Earth term going when she came up next and she namechecked the San Francisco Giants.
对参议员的一个尊重提示。美国人讨厌扬基队。南希·佩洛西在接下来上台时继续保持大地之盐的称呼，她提到了旧金山巨人队。
The speeches had bright spots, but they were largely standard issue, pastel platitudes, a lot of talk about hardworking families left behind and training workers for 21st century economy. There were only about 100 people. This was in a park that could hold thousands. They dutifully clapped when they were supposed to. The Dems called their policy package "A Better Deal." It was a reference to FDR's New Deal, and it came with a slogan that people rattled off in their speeches.
演讲有亮点，但它们主要是标准问题，柔和的陈词滥调，很多关于落后的勤劳家庭和为21世纪经济培训工人的谈论。只有大约100人。这是一个可以容纳数千人的公园。他们在应该鼓掌时顺从地鼓掌。民主党人把他们的政策方案称为“更好的交易”。那是对罗斯福“新政”的参考，它带有一个人们在演讲中脱口而出的口号。
Better jobs, better wages, and a better future.
更好的工作，更好的工资，更好的未来。
Better jobs, better wages, a better future.
Better jobs, better wages, and a better future.
更好的工作，更好的工资，更好的未来。
The slogan, very similar to Papa John's "Better ingredients, better pizza," was mocked almost instantly. Trolling Republican protesters held up pizza boxes that said "Better jobs, better wages, still Pelosi."
那个口号，非常类似于棒约翰的“更好的成分，更好的比萨”，几乎瞬间被嘲笑。嘲弄的共和党抗议者举着写有“更好的工作，更好的工资，还是佩洛西”的比萨盒。
Cheri Bustos was there that day. Bustos was actually one of the architects of the Better Deal. When I asked her more about how the whole plan came together, she said it was a six-month process. It involved 180 members of Congress and all of the caucuses, like progressives, new Dems, Blue Dogs, Black Caucus, Hispanic Caucus. But despite all of that inclusion, the thing that she described, it did in fact sound like subtraction. She said health care, reproductive rights, civil rights, all of those things came up, but moderate Democrats resisted those things. This is the agenda, Bustos said. This is what we're going to be talking about from now until the midterm elections.
切里·布斯托斯那天在那里。布斯托斯实际上是“更好的交易”的建筑师之一。当我问她更多关于整个计划是如何汇总时，她说这是一个六个月的过程。它涉及180名国会议员和所有的党团，如进步派、新民主党人、蓝狗、黑人党团、拉美裔党团。但尽管有所有的包容性，她描述的那件事，它实际上听起来像减法。她说医疗保健、生殖权利、公民权利，所有这些事情都提出来了，但温和派民主党人抵制了那些东西。这是议程，布斯托斯说。这就是我们从现在到中期选举将要谈论的内容。
The next day, I tracked down Keith Ellison in Washington DC. I found him in the tunnels underneath the Capitol on his way to go vote.
第二天，我在华盛顿特区追踪到了基思·埃里森。我在国会大厦下面的隧道里发现了他，他正在去投票的路上。
Benjamin. What's up, my brother?
本杰明。怎么了，兄弟？
Can I ask you some things on the run here?
我可以跑着问你一些事情吗？
Please, please.
请，请。
The first thing I wanted to ask-- as the highest-ranking progressive in the party's power structure, honestly, I was just curious why he hadn't been at the Better Deal rollout. The stage had so many party leaders-- moderates, progressives from the Senate, the House, people in party leadership.
我想要问的第一件事——作为党内权力结构中排名最高的进步派，老实说，我只是很好奇为什么他没有在“更好的交易”发布会上。舞台上有这么多党内领导人——温和派、来自参议院的进步派、众议院、党内领导层的人。
So I went, and there was part of me that was expecting you to be there.
所以我去了，我有一部分是期待你在那里的。
Where?
哪里？
The Better Deal rollout.
“更好的交易”发布会。
Yeah. Well, not everybody can do everything all the time. So no, I wasn't there, but it's all right. So yeah. So--
是的。嗯，不是每个人都能一直做每件事。所以不，我不在那儿，但没关系。所以是的。所以——
At this point, Ellison shot me a look. He looked over his glasses, and he raised his eyebrows, pursed his mouth, like, I know you're asking me a reasonable question, and on a stage filled with party leaders, especially one with only one black member of Congress, I'm the number two guy at the DNC. It would be totally reasonable for you to think that I might be there. But do you see me not talking to you? It made me laugh.
此时，埃里森给了我一个眼神。他透过眼镜看，挑起眉毛，撅起嘴，像，我知道你在问我一个合理的问题，在满是党内领导人的舞台上，特别是只有一个黑人国会议员的舞台上，我是民主党全国委员会的二号人物。你认为我可能在那里是完全合理的。但你看到我没在和你谈话吗？这让我笑了。
Um--
呃——
I don't know what else to say.
我不知道还能说什么。
[LAUGHING] What's that look?
[笑] 那是什么眼神？
Next question.
下一个问题。
All right.
好的。
I asked Ellison what he thought of the Better Deal stuff. He was polite, said he thought it was a good step. Maybe it didn't satisfy everyone, but it was a start. That day, I saw a labor activist tweet that there wasn't anything to help organized labor in the Better Deal. Keith tweeted back, "Don't stress out about what's not in there. Help us promote what is."
我问埃里森他觉得“更好的交易”东西怎么样。他很礼貌，说他认为这是一个好的一步。也许它没有满足每个人，但这是一个开始。那天，我看到一位劳工活动家发推文说在“更好的交易”里没有帮助有组织劳工的东西。基思回推说：“不要因为那里没有的东西而感到压力。帮助我们推广有的东西。”
I later found out Ellison hadn't been invited to the stage in Virginia. And he wasn't the only one. A staffer of a progressive Democrat pointed to another person who was missing-- Bernie Sanders. He laid out this imaginary alternative version of that day, if they'd had Sanders speak.
我后来发现埃里森没有被邀请到弗吉尼亚的舞台。他不是唯一一个。一位进步派民主党人的工作人员指向了另一个失踪的人——伯尼·桑德斯。他描绘了那天假想的替代版本，如果他们让桑德斯发言的话。
He said, how many people were in Virginia? 100? He said, imagine a real crowd, a Sanders-sized crowd. If they put even more Democrats on the stage, lots of them, and they said, we are here to F'ing fight for you, it would have felt different. I asked him why he thought Sanders hadn't been there. Well, they don't like him, he said. They don't get along with him. They don't like that he won't call himself a Democrat.
他说，弗吉尼亚有多少人？100？他说，想象一个真正的人群，桑德斯规模的人群。如果他们在舞台上放入更多的民主党人，很多人，他们说，我们在这里为你操他妈的奋斗，感觉会不同。我问他为什么他认为桑德斯不在那里。嗯，他们不喜欢他，他说。他们和他相处不好。他们不喜欢他拒绝称自己为民主党人。
Eventually, I put that question to Sanders' director of communications, who said, no, Sanders had not been invited. When I asked him why, he said, quote, "I would love to know the answer to that question."
最终，我把那个问题问给了桑德斯的通讯主任，他说，不，桑德斯没有被邀请。当我问他为什么时，他说，引用，“我很想知道那个问题的答案。”
Bernie! Bernie! Bernie!
伯尼！伯尼！伯尼！
In August, I traveled with Senator Bernie Sanders on this tour he did. There were three events, all to build support for universal health care, which he was pushing under the label, "Medicare for All."
八月，我和伯尼·桑德斯参议员一起旅行。有三场活动，全是为了建立对全民医保的支持，他以“全民医保”标签推动。
This sound is from the first rally in Indianapolis, maybe 1,500 people in downtown Indy, on the steps of this huge Civil War monument. The big crowd gathered as rain clouds got darker overhead. And then moments after it started to rain, Sanders came into view, and it sounded like this.
这段声音来自印第安纳波利斯的第一次集会，可能1500人在印第安纳波利斯市中心，在巨大的内战纪念碑台阶上。随着雨云在头顶变黑，大群人聚集在一起。然后开始下雨几分钟后，桑德斯出现在视野中，听起来是这样。
[BANJO PLAYING]
[班卓琴演奏]
[LOUD CHEERING]
[大声欢呼]
There were four straight minutes of screaming. On every stop, Sanders pitches universal health care, but he also talks a lot about all kinds of issues-- race, poverty, immigration, voter suppression. And when he talks about the economy, it's not bland. In fact, he seems like he's having a really hard time not getting mad. His tone is all, these things are epically messed up, and most Americans are getting screwed. And I'm so upset about it, in fact, that my default way of speaking is what most people consider shouting.
有四分钟的尖叫。在每一站，桑德斯都在兜售全民医保，但他也谈论各种议题——种族、贫困、移民、选民压制。而当他谈论经济时，它不是温和的。事实上，他看起来很难不生气。他的基调全都是，这些事情烂透了，大多数美国人被搞惨了。事实上，我对它很不安，以至于我说话的默认方式是大多数人认为的大喊大叫。
The American people know that the economy is rigged. They are working longer hours. And the rich get richer while the poor get poorer. They know that. And when we stand together, black and white and Latino, when we sat together with the Native American people and the Asian-Americans, and gay, and straight, and men, and women, when we stand together, when we have the guts to take on the billionaire class, when we have a vision for a new America, nothing, nothing will stop us. Thank you all, very much.
美国人民知道经济被操纵了。他们工作时间更长。富人越来越富，而穷人越来越穷。他们知道这一点。当我们站在一起时，黑人、白人和拉美裔，当我们和美洲原住民、亚裔美国人、同性恋和异性恋、男人和女人坐在一起时，当我们站在一起，当我们有勇气对抗亿万富翁阶层时，当我们对新美国有愿景时，没有什么，没有什么能阻止我们。非常感谢你们。
After Indianapolis, it was onto Portsmouth, Ohio, a town of 20,000 where Sanders drew a crowd of over 1,000, in the middle of the workday, in a county that Donald Trump won by 37%. Last stop, Detroit, a crowd of around 2,000 in a megachurch, with a spillover crowd in an annex. One moment stuck out. It was near the end.
在印第安纳波利斯之后，是俄亥俄州的朴次茅斯，一个2万人城镇，桑德斯在工作日中间吸引了超过1000人的拥挤，在一个唐纳德·特朗普以37%获胜的县。最后一站，底特律，在一个超大型教堂里约2000人的拥挤，在附楼里还有溢出的人群。一个时刻很突出。接近结束时。
Do not let anybody try to convince you that the views that you've heard here tonight and your views, that we are somehow a small minority. We are not. What the media does not talk about-- yes, there are divisions in this country on a number of issues. I won't deny that. But on major issue after major issue, on every issue that we have talked about, the American people are on our side.
不要让任何人试图说服你，你们今晚在这里听到的观点和你们的观点，我们不知何故是小少数。我们不是。媒体不谈论的是——是的，这个国家在许多问题上存在分歧。我不会否认这一点。但在主要问题之后的主要问题上，在我们谈论的每一个问题上，美国人民都在我们这边。
The polls back this up. Like, there are polls showing that most Americans do favor universal health care. Most Americans-- get ready for this one, this number comes from a Fox News poll of all places. 83% of Americans support a path to citizenship for undocumented immigrants. And 76% of Americans say rich people should pay more in taxes.
民意调查支持这一点。比如，有民意调查显示大多数美国人确实支持全民医保。大多数美国人——准备好这个，这个数字来自福克斯新闻民意调查。83%的美国人支持非法移民入籍途径。76%的美国人说富人应该多纳税。
Chuck Schumer, Nancy Pelosi, and the DNC are supposedly in charge of the party, but it's Sanders who has the profile and the power base to determine what Democrats in the country are talking about. This trip was evidence of just how true that is.
查克·舒默、南希·佩洛西和民主党全国委员会被认为负责该党，但桑德斯拥有确定全国民主党人在谈论什么的形象和权力基础。这次旅行证明了这一点有多真实。
Over the summer, I talked to moderate Democrats in Congress who thought Sanders was going to push single-payer health. They were dreading it. They worried they'd be pressured to support it, that it would become part of the Democrats' brand, part of what the party's about. And if it did, they'd get hammered back in their districts, which are more conservative. Cheri Bustos called it self-sabotage. We don't need any self-sabotage, she told me.
夏天，我和国会中的温和派民主党人谈话，他们认为桑德斯会推动单一付款人医保。他们很担心。他们担心会被施压支持它，它会成为民主党品牌的一部分，成为该党代表的一部分。如果这样做，他们在选区会受到打击，选区更保守。切里·布斯托斯称之为自我破坏。我们不需要任何自我破坏，她告诉我。
But leaning on Democrats to embrace single-payer was precisely Sanders' goal. According to Sanders' director of communications, Sanders wanted to get Democratic senators to publicly support single-payer, including potential presidential candidates for 2020, because that way, he said, single-payer would become something that other candidates would feel pressured to support.
但让民主党拥抱单一付款人正是桑德斯的目标。据桑德斯的通讯主任称，桑德斯想要让民主党参议员公开支持单一付款人，包括2020年的潜在总统候选人，因为那样，他说，单一付款人会成为其他候选人会感到被施压支持的东西。
And over the summer, one by one, Democratic senators signed on, way more than they expected. They were hoping for five or six, but they got 10, then 15, eventually, a third of all Democratic senators. The list included potential presidential candidates like Cory Booker, Kamala Harris, Elizabeth Warren, and Kirsten Gillibrand.
整个夏天，一个接一个，民主党参议员签署了，比他们预期的多得多。他们希望有五或六个，但他们得到了10个，然后15个，最终，三分之一的所有民主党参议员。名单包括像科里·布克、卡玛拉·哈里斯、伊丽莎白·沃伦和柯斯滕·吉利布兰德这样的潜在总统候选人。
At Sanders' final stop in Detroit, the Congressman hosting the event had put out the Democratic Party's Better Deal materials. They were laid out right next to the front door, as people streamed in. There were these huge, conspicuous piles. But over several hours, I didn't see anyone pick them up. As the crowd filtered out, I circled back. From what I could see, they hadn't been touched.
在桑德斯在底特律的最后一站，主持活动的国会议员放出了民主党“更好的交易”材料。它们就在前门旁边放下，人们涌入。有巨大、显眼的堆。但几个小时内，我没看到任何人拿它们。随着人群滤出，我折回。据我所见，它们没被动过。
A few days later, I got to see Cheri Bustos pitching the Better Deal to a newspaper editorial board in her home state. Bustos laid out the whole thing, the Better Deal, how it was created, all the involvement from congressional Democrats, all the different parts of it.
几天后，我看到切里·布斯托斯在家乡向报纸编辑部推销“更好的交易”。布斯托斯摆出了所有东西，更好的交易，它是如何创造的，国会民主党人的所有参与，它的所有不同部分。
We want to be in a position to help create 10 million good-paying, full-time jobs. There are still people hurting, and I think we need to acknowledge that and say that we want to do something about that.
我们想要处于一个帮助创造1000万份薪水好、全职工作的职位。仍然有人受伤，我认为我们需要承认这一点并说我们想要对此做些事情。
Right. Well, Donald Trump says that, too.
对。嗯，唐纳德·特朗普也这么说。
It's hard to hear. The newspaper's political reporter, this guy named Chuck Sweeney, is saying, "Right. Well, Donald Trump says that too."
听起来很艰难。报纸的政治记者，这个叫查克·斯威尼的家伙，正在说，“对。嗯，唐纳德·特朗普也这么说。”
Donald Trump says that too. He says exactly the same thing. Too many people are still out of work. You know, we need to do something about bringing back jobs.
唐纳德·特朗普也这么说。他说了完全一样的话。太多人仍然失业。你知道，我们需要做一些关于带回工作的事情。
And that's why we talk about full-time, good-paying jobs.
这就是为什么我们谈论全职、薪水好的工作。
Right. But--
对。但——
Well, I think there are people hurting.
嗯，我认为有人受伤。
I don't know anybody that doesn't talk about that, so--
我不认识不谈论那个的人，所以——
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
Remember, the whole point of the Better Deal was to explain what Democrats stand for, to define Democrats in terms that would resonate in places exactly like this one. Bustos forged ahead. Eventually, she started talking about how she's pro-business, one of the things that makes her moderate. She told the editorial board she thought it would be a good idea to lower the corporate tax rate. This was months before Donald Trump's corporate tax cut.
记住，“更好的交易”全部意义在于解释民主党代表什么，以能在像这里一样的地方产生共鸣的术语来定义民主党。布斯托斯继续前进。最终，她开始谈论她如何支持商业，这是使她成为温和派的事情之一。她告诉编辑部她认为降低企业税率是个好主意。这是在唐纳德·特朗普企业减税前几个月。
So Democrats do support reducing corporate tax rates?
所以民主党确实支持减少企业税率？
Yeah, it's got bipartisan support, this--
是的，它有两党支持，这个——
What should the rate be?
税率应该是多少？
You know, I don't know. I don't know what it should be, but ours is one of the highest in the world.
你知道，我不知道。我不知道它应该是多少，但我们的是世界上最高的之一。
Right.
对。
And so as long as it's highest in the world, we're not going to have corporations who are going to bring that money home. So there's got to be some incentive.
所以只要它是世界上最高的，我们就不会有要把钱带回来的公司。所以必须有一些激励。
OK. I didn't-- see, I think, once again, I have no idea what the Democratic Party actually stands for anymore. I didn't during the 2016 campaign, either, which is probably why it wasn't the winning campaign.
好的。我没——看，我认为，再一次，我不知道民主党现在到底代表什么。我在2016年竞选期间也不知道，这可能就是为什么它不是获胜的竞选。
A couple top Democrats told me things usually get messy after a party loses the presidency. The thing is, our national parties are chaotic. When a party loses the presidency, it's like you take the sun out of the solar system. Everyone wants to go in their own direction until a new, definitive leader for the party emerges. Even with their steakhouse meeting, the Republicans had their own kind of chaos during the Obama years, with the Tea Party and moderates getting primaried out of office.
几个顶级民主党人告诉我，事情通常在党失去总统职位后变得混乱。事情是，我们的全国政党是混乱的。当一个党失去总统职位时，就像你把太阳从太阳系拿走。每个人都想要朝自己的方向去，直到该党出现新的、明确的领导人。即使有他们的牛排馆会议，共和党人在奥巴马年代也有他们自己的那种混乱，茶党和温和派被初选赶出办公室。
For the Democrats, in the meantime, the party is torn. It's putting money into both of these strategies at the same time. Cheri Bustos just released a report called "Hope From the Heartland." It's kind of a blueprint for Democrats to turn things around in the Midwest. Keith Ellison got the party to invest a chunk of its limited funds in grassroots organizing-- not in targeted swing districts, but across all 50 states, states as red as Wyoming and as blue as Vermont.
对于民主党人，在此期间，该党被撕裂了。它同时在把钱投入这两个战略中。切里·布斯托斯刚刚发布了一份名为“来自心脏地带的希望”的报告。这是民主党人扭转在美中局面的一种蓝图。基思·埃里森让该党把其有限资金的一块投入草根组织——不是在有针对性的摇摆选区，而是在所有50个州，像怀俄明一样红和像佛蒙特一样蓝的州。
I called them both last week to ask if the Democrats' victories this fall in Alabama, in Virginia, in New Jersey, if that shed any light on which path the party should take going into the midterms. Cheri told me they clearly demonstrated that she was right about the party's direction. Keith, no surprise, said they proved his vision of the future is correct. I'm more convinced than ever, he said. More convinced than ever.
我上周打电话给他们两个，问民主党今年秋天在阿拉巴马、弗吉尼亚、新泽西的胜利，这是否揭示了该党在中期选举前应该采取哪条道路。切里告诉我它们清楚地证明了她在该党方向上是对的。基思，不奇怪，说它们证明了他对未来的愿景是正确的。我比以往任何时候都更确信，他说。比以往任何时候都更确信。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our program.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目制片人之一。
MUSIC - "HARDER THAN IT LOOKS" BY SULO]
音乐 - “比看起来更难”作者：SULO]
Our program was produced today by Robyn Semien. The people who put our show together include Elna Baker, Elise Bergerson, Ben Calhoun, Whitney Dangerfield, Stephanie Foo, Michelle Harris, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Alvin Melathe, Jonathan Menjivar, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们的节目今天由罗宾·塞米恩制作。把我们节目放在一起的人包括埃尔纳·贝克、爱丽丝·伯格森、本·卡尔霍恩、惠特尼·丹格菲尔德、斯蒂芬妮·福、米歇尔·哈里斯、塞斯·林德、米基·米克、阿尔文·梅拉西、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和朱莉·惠特克。我们的资深制作人是布莱恩·里德。我们的执行编辑是苏珊·伯顿。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This is the last week at our show for Jonathan Menjivar, who you heard in Act One. He's been here for seven years. He's added funny, smart, elegant writing to all of our stories, including mine. He was in charge of music for the show. We'll miss him. We wish him the best at his new job, at a podcast company called Pineapple Street Media.
这是乔纳森·门吉瓦尔在我们节目的最后一周，你在第一幕听到了。他在这里待了七年。他为我们所有的故事添加了有趣、聪明、优雅的写作，包括我的。他负责节目的音乐。我们会想念他。我们祝他在新工作，在一家叫菠萝街媒体的播客公司里一切顺利。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, I think we're going to have to stop going to eat in Little Italy. He is just so embarrassing whenever the server comes around.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，我想我们得停止去小意大利吃饭了。每当服务员过来时，他总是太尴尬了。
Me hablo mucho Italiano. Entiendo un poquito Español.
我懂很多意大利语。我也懂一点西班牙语。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。